très bon soir stéphane leblanc bonjour
rarement at-on vu autant de
questionnements d'inquiétude
d'incertitude la part des gens on va se
lancer tout de suite avec les questions
puis on va vous demander de répondre
succinctement bien sûr à chacune des
questions et très précisément tout de
suite une première question nous sommes
deux propriétaires d'une entreprise de
10 employés
nous avons mis la majorité de nos
employés au chômage mais nous avons
gardé une personne en comptabilité avons
nous droit à la subvention salariale et
qu'est ce qui arrive avec nos salaires
comme propriétaire oui pour la personne
qui a gardé son emploi l'employeur va
avoir le droit à la subvention salariale
un montant qui est une baisse de revenus
par rapport à mars 2010 versus mars 2019
mais ça ça devrait être le cas si on a
fermé et la subvention aussi va pouvoir
s'appliquer sur les salaires des deux
propriétaires donc on va avoir les
droits pour les trois îles trois
employés restants la société à la
subvention salariale donc la subvention
salariale on peut la voir même si on
réembauche pas tout le monde
effectivement effectivement c'est pas un
critère donc on à la subvention sur les
employés qu'on continue à payer parfait
deuxième question j'ai une compagnie de
construction je suis le seul travailleur
qui se verse 50 mille dollars de
dividendes par année tous mes contrats
ont été annulés
est ce qu'il ya de l'aide pour moi
malheureusement il n'ya pas d'être dans
cette situation là en fonction de ce qui
est étonnant aussi je crée mes mains par
le gouvernement c'est une situation qui
est soulevé leur style souvent que
l'employeur grosse noix de travers comme
ça va se lasser soit des salaires pour
l'édile dame mais ça ça n'a pas été
prévu d'autres prestations canadiennes
d'urgence et pas de subvention dans ces
cas là où le travailleur de ce pays et
se fondent et il donne pas ce qu'elle
veut c'est ça ton accompagne le
dividende n'est pas considérée comme un
revenu d'emploi revenu de travail
acceptée par le programme
la prestation canadienne d'urgence j'ai
un petit commerce qui a dû fermer
je n'ai pas de salarié j'ai fait moins
de 5000 $ en revenus d'emplois l'an
dernier j'ai déclaré une perte
d'entreprise en raison d'un incendie
je dispose d'une prestation de retraite
qui couvrira mes frais fixes alors je
tombe sans aucun revenu disponible
j'ai droit à quoi la maison ici dans
cette situation là malheureusement
autant le programme de subvention
salariale peut posséder qui parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas de revenus d'emploi donc
et paiement d'emploi et il avait une
chose du niveau des prestations
d'urgence donc il laisse sept personnes
là ne peut pas qualifier malheureusement
il reste peut-être le 400 dollars de
crédits dps qui qui va s'appliquer qui
vois-tu supplémentaires selon le montant
du revenu de répit donc c'est un peu ça
la situation pour cette personne de
malheureuses donc il ya vraiment des
gens qui tombent dans les cas quand
comment audi le puits qui ne rendent pas
justement dans les programmes compte
tenu des critères autre question mon
mail et à une entreprise à stornoway et
il a deux employés qui travaillent avec
lui s'il demande la subvention à 75% du
gouvernement fédéral
est ce que ces employés peuvent
travailler deux jours dans la semaine
vu qu'il a perdu plus de 30% de son
chiffre d'affaires oui les employés
peuvent travailler deux jours et
d'enfants le gouvernement va payer la
subvention ou être calculée sur les
montants que vous versés aux employés
pour ces deux jours leur donc ça va être
la même chose pour pour son mari
également à qui pourraient avoir le
droit au faux pas lui mais laisse la
société var ont le droit à la subvention
nous avons acheté en septembre dernier
un restaurant notre incorporation date
de moins de 12 mois se noue admissibles
à la subvention salariale
c'est un cas qui était prévu donc pour
les entreprises qui sont établis après
le février 2019
l'admissibilité au lieu de comparer les
revenus de mars 2020 aux revenus de mars
2009 on va pouvoir une base de revenus
une comparaison de revenus mensuels que
qu'on va juger raisonnable donc pour
l'établir si on a droit à la subvention
donc si réellement une baisse de revenus
un exemple si vous avez tous fermer
complètement pas de commerces et de
restaurants menace tout moment là vous
devriez est admissible de la prestation
vocale et avec des vins du rhône où et
comment il faut en parler avec l' agence
du revenu
ben j'imagine que dans la demande ça
votre travail et spécifie de démontrer
que notre base raisonnable pour montrer
qu'on est con on est con à bessines des
revenus de temps pour sa part fait le
portail sera bientôt lancée pour la
subvention salariale n'est pas encore
disponible
nous sommes une entreprise privée
canadienne
mais pour laquelle l'actionnaire unique
est un groupe européen
sommes-nous admissibles à la subvention
salariale oui toutes les entreprises
sont admissibles dont qu'il ait pas de
critères au niveau de la détention de
l'actionnaire et en autant qu'on
respecte les critères d'âge est de 30
pour sexe toutes les entreprises sont
parfaits les gens l'incorporation qui
travaillent seuls qui n'ont pas de
salarié pas d'assurance emploi et qui ne
sont pas entreprises essentiellement
t-il droit à la prestation d'urgence bon
encore pour venir à la règle de base
pour le droit à la prestation d'urgence
donc si la personne incorporer ces pays
un salaire un pic ont dû arrêter leur
entreprise est là qu il ne se paye plus
de salaires donc qu'ils respectent les
conditions de 5000 $ de revenu d'appoint
2019 dans les 12 derniers mois et qui ne
plus de revenus par la 14 jours
consécutifs ils devraient ils devaient
pouvoir de droit à la prestation de jean
pierre como de vue tantôt si spriet sous
forme de dividendes parce qu'on parle de
l'incorporation restaurant l'eau il
répond doigts autre question je
travaille dans un organisme de charité
est ce que nous allons pouvoir
bénéficier de la subvention salariale
oui la subvention moyens disponibles
pour les organismes de charité pour les
organismes sans but lucratif
par contre au niveau du critère de
baisse des revenus
on s'attendait vraiment voir revenir
avec des détails pour comment ça va être
appliquée dans le secteur des organismes
de charité parce que dans le fond c'est
pas tout les organisateurs
lt qui ont nécessairement des revenus
est ce qu'on va considérer les donations
et cetera donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est à venir qui vont
être développés avec les gouvernements
les discussions à ce sujet là il faut
noter aussi que la subvention a quand
même si c'est pas la personne qui
travaille pour l'organisme qui veulent
avancer l'organisme absolue shalit et
qui va avoir le droit à la subvention
nous avec une autre question ma boutique
est encore ouverte je paie une employée
mais je ne me verse plus de salaire
est-ce que j'ai droit à la prestation
d'urgence ici pour faire la passion
parce qu'il ya un critère qui était mis
dans la loi pour la prestation d'urgence
et qu'il ne faut pas qu on se connait un
arrêt qui est considéré comme un départ
volontaire
donc est ce que la personne comme elie
indirectement sa propre l'employeur est
ce que le fait que l arrêt de se payer
peut être considérée comme indépendante
par le gouvernement donc si c'est quand
vasco moment là on n'aurait pas droit à
la prestation d'urgence dans ce cas ci
mais c'est quelque chose qui est un
petit peu on a demandé de
l'interprétation à faire dans ces
situations-là petites zones d'ombré mon
employeur couper dans mes heures en
raison de la crise
est ce que j'ai le droit de l'aide mais
ça aussi c'est une situation qui est
prévu dans le sens où si on continuera
sa voix reste un revenu d'emploi parce
que nos joueurs ont été réduits parce
que j'ai pas le droit à la prestation de
jean donc le fait de continuer à gagner
un revenu d'emploi parce que je
travaille déjà réduit ne me permet pas
d'avoir la prestation du jeu donc et pas
d'autres
d'autre chose de prévu pour ces gens-là
parfaite je suis travailleur autonome je
n'ai plus de revenus depuis plus de
quatorze jours si je vends des produits
en ligne
est-ce que je vais perdre la prestation
la prestation de jean ce donc se fait
par carrier la période de quatre
semaines
donc faut pas que j'ai eue de revenus
pendant 14 jours consécutifs pendant
cette période de quatre semaines là donc
si vous vendez les produits en ligne
vous aviez arrêté pour 14 jours
ben qu'oui peut pas être qualifié pour
la paix une période de quatre semaines
si vous respectez le test de 14 jours
consécutifs par contre si par la suite
pourriez perdre votre prestation
d'urgence pour le dépôt de la prochaine
période de quatre semaines puisqu'on est
tout le temps en présence de
on a quatre fois des quêtes des périodes
de quatre semaines donc le fait de
gagner revenant à lille pourrait faire
perdre par la suite la prestation
d'objets on y va avec une petite
dernière un étudiant qui a fait plus de
5000 $ dans les 12 derniers mois mais
qui n'a pas perdu son emploi à cause de
la coved 19 et si l'accès à la
prestation non seulement été clair sur
son site
les étudiants qui ont pas perdu leur
emploi à cause du kavé 19e n'auront pas
le droit à la prestation du jeune et
quand on dit gagner au moins 5000 $ dans
les 12 derniers mois ces cinq mille
dollars bruts n'est ce pas ouais c'est
bien ça c'est 5000 $ comparé du la
rémunération brute que l'employeur pays
avant les déductions à la source le qui
voit qu'ils sont prélevés normalement
très clair stéphane leblanc merci
beaucoup merci